hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar
and today i will be discussing the very
latest
game changing events in the black clover
story
including asta's brand new power true
demon power
which may have just ended the biggest
battle of the current war arc
asta and yami have demonstrated
incredible teamwork
and despite dante's overpowered body
magic
and gravity magic it looks like the big
battle might be over
but let's not rush to judgment because
we have been fooled before
many times and of course we can't forget
about the potential
consequences that asta will have to
accept in exchange for using this
incredible new power that he just used
there is so much to talk about things
are absolutely crazy in the story right
now so let's
get into it if you enjoyed the black
lover content on this channel and you
want to see
more you know what to do leave a like to
let me know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or you
just haven't subscribed yet make this
the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications a big thank you to all of
our anime outpour patrons who make
videos like this one possible
i will talk more about patreon at the
end of the video but until then
please be advised that this video will
contain black clover manga spoilers
we are dealing with the latest events in
the story so please proceed with caution
you have been warned in the previous
installment of the story
asta made a deal with his devil or demon
in order to get access to true demon
power
the anti-magic demon said that asta
would have to give him a body part in
exchange
for his power and asta agreed because he
was willing to do anything in order to
get stronger
and help yami defeat dante hosta
realizes that he can't become the wizard
king
if he can't handle the demon's true
power and he can't live up to yami's
expectations
if he doesn't get much stronger very
quickly in the final panel of the
previous chapter
we saw that asta's right arm was
completely consumed
by demonic darkness and the new chapter
kicks off with asta
using his newly unlocked true demon
power against
dante but the anti-magic demon informs
asta that his newfound power
won't last very long apparently this is
not the same demonic darkness that had
spread around asta's body
in the past this darkness is true demon
power itself
and asta will only be able to use it for
about 50 seconds so less than a minute
from what we've been told by the
anti-magic demon it seems that asta's
right arm is now
practically the demon's own arm what i
mean by that is
this arm is no longer just a vessel for
the anti-magic demon's power
the arm itself has become that power in
its truest
form despite the revelation that he will
only be able to use this power for like
less than a minute
asta says that this is enough and he
wastes
no time asta immediately attacks dante
and dante can tell right away that
something about hosta has changed
yami notices that dante has become
extremely wary of asta
dante even used his body magic to grow
additional arms and he arms himself with
like four gravity swords and it seems
that he is doing all of this
in order to reduce his chances of being
hit by asta
yami realizes that one clean hit from
asta could
end this entire fight so he instantly
joins asta and both of them give it
their all
against the insanely overpowered dante
finral notices that aston yami are using
remarkable teamwork tactics
as they face off against the gigantic
and monstrous dante
the two of them are moving practically
in unison and even in a life or death
situation like this one
it is clear that yami and asta are
actually having fun
it actually makes perfect sense that
yami and asta would make such a good
team
and of course i love to see them working
together like this during
such a major battle not only have these
guys known each other for quite a while
because they are members of the same
squad but both austin yami can read
key and this very rare ability allows
them to work together in a way that
other mages who can't read ki just
wouldn't be able to do
at least that is my opinion the fight
rages on and dante continues to take
damage from yami
but he also continues to dodge direct
hits from asta
which allows him to keep regenerating at
this point we get some really really
good battle panels
in the manga but before you know it
asta's limit for using his true demon
power
runs down to only 8 seconds and so
asta attempts to end the fight by
summoning his demon dweller sword
dante prevents asta from using the demon
dweller sword by wrapping osta
up in his grotesque flesh magic asta
then summons the demon destroyer sword
right out of his grimoire but dante is
able to disrupt asta's attack
yet again after a new attack from yami
dante regenerates yet again
and there are now only three seconds
left before asta has to relinquish his
true demon power
so he is quickly running out of options
at the very last moment
with like a single second left dante
throws his
own katana over to asta asta grabs the
sword with his right hand
encases the sword in anti-magic and
delivers
a direct kessagiri cut to dante's body
by the way asta's kesagiri form is
surprisingly good for someone who has
presumably never used a katana
let alone studied iaido or kendo but hey
let's go with it everyone is stunned as
dante's body
suddenly reverts back to his normal
human form
and the crown flies off his head as a
dark scar
made of anti-magic runs down the side of
his torso
the end of the chapter suggests that
yami and asta have won
and that dante has been defeated
although
personally i wouldn't rush to judgement
just yet
this was definitely an excellent battle
i loved the teamwork between yami and
asta
and i loved the fact that asta was able
to unleash the true power
of his demon but i still wouldn't be
surprised if dante
somehow survives this after all the
times we've seen dante regenerate
i won't make any speculations about his
death or defeat until we have official
confirmation
we also can't forget that his demon
lucifer
is one of the strongest high ranked
demons so who knows what he is still
capable of doing
let's say the dante really is done for
does that necessarily mean
that lucifer is also defeated or
could the demon still cling to this
world and potentially possess
another host i just don't see a high
ranked demon with a name
as important as lucifer going down so
easily
but hey you never know so we'll have to
wait and see
what did you guys think about aston
yami's teamwork and do you think that
using yami's sword allowed asta to
actually
mix dark magic and anti-magic during his
attack
or was it just anti-magic that
ultimately hit dante
i think that the whole asta needing to
use yami's sword was a really nice touch
by tabata
and i really enjoyed that moment a
moment that showcased the great trust
and camaraderie that these two
characters have and
since these are literally my two
favorite characters in the entire series
i absolutely loved seeing this finally
i want to ask you guys something so feel
free to share your thoughts down in the
comments
below what do you think will be the
consequences for asta's decision to use
true demon power
even if it was only for a few seconds
will this deal with the devil now give
more control of his body to the demon
will he lose control of that arm in the
long run
will his personality change because of
the demon
it seems that whenever in fiction any
sort of deal with the devil is made
there are always very real consequences
so i'm very curious to see
what will happen to asta now will the
anti-magic demon just be like oh i like
you asta
so it's all good fam or will we see some
real consequences for asta in the long
term
let me know what you think down below if
you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
black clover content on the channel
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime
pro or you just haven't had a chance to
subscribe please consider subscribing
and hitting that notification bell to
turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all you can also hit me up on twitter
and
instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime opera patrons who make videos
like this one possible
a special thank you to all of our the
one tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata alolan
adam
the world steelers a quiet respect
pate heffa jonathan king brandon aviles
papa smurf the school bus king riser
emperor otaku ricardo martinez
thomas jones ken mono michael hyde and
jaden the vector and i can't forget all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one
and only gilgamesh nothing but a fan
jason wilson
kings eldress anatoly kazotsky angel
cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
octor jessica kayla fond hinokamien
water bonnie parks zodiard
12 wrathween de ora kraken arl's
deadly saint and stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our exclusive
anime outpour patron discord and your
name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you